it's an
early 2000s dance party at the lopez
rodriguez house
and it looks like a freaking blast i'm
ready are you ready yeah i'm ready i'm
excited about it
on thursday jennifer lopez hit up tick
tock to share a clip with her fiance
alex rodriguez his 12 year old daughter
ella
her 12 year old daughter emmy and
chicago white sox player nick
silva dancing to a ton of hits from the
early 2000s
[Music]
yeah we're talking ja rule and ashanti
[Music]
even a little t-pain
[Music]
gotta love that auto-tune you know this
dance party is a vibe
and i want it
[Music]
is
[Music]
these bops had me hype party in club
basement
seriously all that was missing was a
little jenny from the block
but this isn't the first time the bomb
of two has slayed on tick tock
thank you who couldn't forget back in
march when a-rod danced around in his
ladies dress
for the whole internet to see what can i
tell you the former new york yankees
player took on the flip the switch
challenge
and let me warn you you can't unsee it
these two really are tick-tock couple
goals i mean their couple goals
period you look like you having the damn
time of your life
what do i i have nothing to complain
about i mean my life right now is just
so amazing uh my personal life you know
my kids
everything everything's just in a great
place and i feel really lucky
yeah but seriously nothing to complain
about the triple threat damn near broke
tick tock when she shared this
sexy beach clip in march
guys she is 51 freaking 51.
how proud are you very very proud and on
that note let me send you off by
returning
to that epic throwback dance party
[Music]
it's your birthday
you